China is not too happy about that whole
Lab leak thing the Communist Nation
slamming the FBI and accusing the Bureau
of politicizing the deadly virus and
wants America to respect science and
facts but that's not going to deter FBI
director Christopher Ray this is what he
said he thinks the Chinese are hiding
I will just make the observation that
the Chinese government seems to me has
been doing its best
to try to thwart
an obfuscate
the work here the work that we're doing
the work that our U.S government and
close foreign partners are doing
and that's unfortunate for everybody
China clearly wants to move on and a
former Biden covet advisor might agree
even if the Chinese were to come forward
and say nobody in their lab had been
infected that they did not have this
virus in the lab would do anybody in the
world believe them and so I think we
have to move on and I I worry that we're
wasting time getting prepared for the
next virus to hit us and all of that
comes as Congress kicks off their Prime
Time hearings on China One witness says
China poses more threats than the Soviet
Union ever did
in general do you think that China poses
a greater threat
uh to our freedom and the world's
freedom than the Soviet Union ever did
Congressman yes yes I do
and this from Congressman Jim Banks who
was asking about what uh one of the
witnesses thought could be happening
inside the lab
do you think there is a chance that the
Wuhan lab was involved in bioweapons
research
well I I think that we know for certain
that the Chinese military uh is involved
in Research into coronaviruses okay so
that doesn't
bode well for the world so it looked
like it was a dual use lab you look at
it for science but you also look at it
for Bio weapons and that's why we were
sending some of these grants over there
to finance the gain of function but also
get a little window into what they were
researching to kill us and that's
probably why the CIA was like I don't
really know what's going on
but if it was bio and they did it on
purpose it backfired because now the
whole world hates China it kind of
slowed their economic momentum down and
now we took a lot of our factories out
of there and we're strangling them with
export and import controls I don't think
that
China is necessarily a bigger threat
than Russia was if you just look back at
it the nuclear weapons capability of
Russia at the time was crazy they had
more of a worldwide ideological threat
in Latin America and Asia we lost a lot
of guys and the Korean War lost a lot of
men in Vietnam but I guess China is more
of an economic threat
listen
if the FBI the energy Department which
runs bio Labs all over the world
three whistleblowers and all of my
friends in the virus Community all say
that this thing is man-made then I'm
going to go with that instead of Dr
fauci Who was China's lab partner he was
the lab partner of the guy that killed a
million Americans and it's amazing that
after two years the Democrats did
nothing on this all they did was
investigate January 6th and then all of
a sudden the Republicans come in and we
finally start getting some answers to
what happened here and still the
Democrats are still covering up not only
are they covering up the January 6
investigation but they're covering up
the lab leak situation what a bunch of
you know what
wow you sound like me you know what
almost I was almost offended what about
the guy who says Let's just move on oh
let's just move on he's a c word
a crackpot
um yeah be suspicious of anyone who says
we gotta move on you don't move on from
seven million dead right we need this
this can't be a show trial it can't just
be China China the way Jan six was Trump
trump it can't be for political gain you
have to have specific goals and reach
conclusions who was involved what was
done figure out what we're going to do
and then we hang them no I don't I don't
know what we do I love the uh uh the lab
leak deniers what their excuses now
you're seeing the excuses come out their
excuses are well the people that were
pro-lab leak well they were Republicans
so there probably were racist right
there because it's China so we couldn't
be on that side so it's their fault for
being right because they're bigots it
wasn't our fault for feeling that way
now you felt that way they weren't
racist you felt that way and you're
blaming your stupid feelings on the uh
on well you're blaming your mistake on
your stupid feelings crazy how the left
prioritizes evil right the same people
who call it a hate crime when you dead
name someone probably have never heard
of the uyghurs right they don't know
about the child labor that goes into
their iPhones and their shoes or that
China probably killed their grandparents
but damn you better not use the wrong
pronoun that's where we are you forgot
all the all the coal-fired power plants
are using that's another one right thank
you Dana the other thing that the
Chinese have said is that we're being
our government is being very overhanded
and that we're like an authoritarian
government yeah yeah apparently the
People's Republic of China demanded that
the house select committee stop
denigrating the Communist Party of China
I I I think they should not only
denigrate but they should delegitimize
them as far as we're concerned we should
be decoupling from China but we can't do
that because we have so many things that
are made in China that we need like all
kinds of medicines and that's the
problem but I'm hoping that this thing
the problem with China and and I agree I
mean to say you can't do two things at
one time I mean are you stupid I mean we
can't we've just got to get get on to
making sure we're prepared for the next
pandemic instead of trying to figure out
what happened to the last one oh we
could only do you know that's what cost
to cause that one that's planning the
next one yeah but you know extent that
China is involved in the in the in in
the uh fentanyl undeclared war that
we've been talking about they should be
declared a transnational drug
organization because they're killing
Americans it is an undeclared war and we
were their lab partner uh we were
funding through the Echo Health Alliance
and everybody's covering their butt and
that's a sad situation but I'm hoping
that China maybe can bring Democrats and
Republicans together that maybe if we
realize the danger of this country and
what they're trying to do to us
politically and economically and
socially I mean it is it is frightening
so actually I was gonna that's why I
wanted to ask Jessica about is just how
bipartisan this committee actually was
and yesterday there was no sniping it
towards each other there was no snark it
was like serious and smart and they
brought people together in a prime time
do you think that can continue
hope so as long as Republicans are in
charge
yeah I'd like to say something about
what Jesse said about Democrats
um obscuring what happened on January
6th since we were the only ones plus Liz
Cheney and Adam kensinger who cared to
actually talk about it and in hearings
but I think that we can maintain it
there was a rally in the over the
weekend here actually on the Lower East
Side against the Chinese Communist Party
led by Richie Torres and Mike Gallagher
from Wisconsin a Republican and a
Democrat
um I think that it is something that can
go forward and to your point about
why can't we do two things at once why
can't you just say it's feasible that it
came from a lab and it was low
Confidence from the Department of energy
and a little bit higher Confidence from
the FBI and that people shouldn't have
been racist like it's a bad thing to
walk around beating up Asian people and
saying it's Kung Fu and it's possible
you don't have proof that that was
connected no that's the that's not the
problem the problem is there's a lot of
anti-asian violence sure had nothing to
do with Trump calling it the Chinese
people you don't think there's something
else going on you know that I know how
to point too I have shorter arms so it's
less offensive
yes
yes that's very long I felt like that
was a microaggression yeah and me being
micro I know what you're eating my time
um
there is a direct correlation to having
a virus that is killing people in this
country that we know came from China
there was a huge spike in it and I know
that it was more black people that were
beating up Asian people than white
people that it was ridiculous to call it
a function of white supremacists
I didn't
eat it up eat that time up go ahead
that's really irritating
Jon Stewart is the best about this if
you haven't seen him with Stephen
Colbert where he's talking about the
fact this was probably a lab leak and he
does this hilarious thing where he says
you know there's a big flood of
chocolate in Hershey Pennsylvania yeah
we did the same thing but you weren't
there but we made that same well I was
on maternity leave because I made life
okay
watch the old clip and Jon Stewart is
awesome watch it all and watch us when
we come right back everyone or Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now